i believe uh what has changed in the uk
is i think we've seen an unprecedented
verdict in a case like george floyd
uh the state versus derek shelvin
seeing a police officer actually
convicted of murder and a murder that
was committed
while he was in the line of duty so that
was an unprecedented
uh verdict here in the usa it
it seems remar i mean i know there are
concerns about what is happening here
in in the united kingdom but it still
seems
astounding to a lot of us but when we
look at the levels of division that have
existed
still in the united states
i mean the murder of george floyd as
tragic
as it is do you think it is going to be
a
a catalyst for some sort of change
you know i've already seen it be a
catalyst for change
and there needs to be a continual change
not only in the usa but around the world
you know uh one of the things i've
noticed about many of the viewers
on some of my previous interviews is
that
you know a lot of people want to default
to narratives
of hate and judgment
everybody in the world saw what happened
everybody saw derek shoving commit that
murder
but sometimes it seems that people of
opposite opinion
want to point to previous incidents
where there's really no proof there's
really no video evidence
um and we all can agree that it was a
very hateful thing that happened to mr
floyd
and we don't need that in the usa we
don't need it in the uk we don't need it
anywhere in the world
um what why do you think it is that
people
do always well certainly a lot of the
time and i've seen it myself
they refer back to to george's
your troubled history if we can if we
can use
those terms why do people refer back to
that because it
i guess it doesn't matter how troubled
he was or how much trouble he'd been in
it still obviously doesn't justify what
happened to him
absolutely there's no justification for
that and the jury
in this case you know they found it that
to be the case the gentleman was guilty
and listened
you know for the viewers also you know
this this punishment
was nothing about being against the
police this was not an anti-police
verdict it was an anti-derek shelvin
verdict
because what he did was very heinous
very horrible
so the goal is of to god be the glory
really in the memory of george floyd is
to unite the people
unite the people with police so that
there can be a harmonious existence and
a better understanding
between the two yeah i mean how do you
go about
doing that because it's understandable i
know they've been they've been
long time divisions between some parts
of the black community
and the police in the united states and
exacerbated by things like this
of course how do you go about bringing
back a
a level of trust in the police amongst
members of the black community
well i appreciate that uh with to god be
the glory sports you know george floyd
being a member of to god be the glory
sports early in our existence
our goal is to unite the police and
citizens from the community through
sports programs
right now we're we're developing
different sports programs that
can get police officers uh having
recreational leagues
people from the different communities
and this way can break the ice
and just establish a rapport good will
between the two groups because we all
need each other in society
the police needs the community to be
supportive and vice versa we just need
to reestablish that trust between the
two
and presumably part of that as well is i
mean i know that you know there are
there are plenty of black police
officers in the united states but
it's about increasing that number isn't
it increasing representation
certainly in in some key areas
uh you know i think there are a number
of issues that need to be addressed i
think that you hit
i think that you hit the nail on the
head earlier
when it's just the overall trust i don't
think it's a matter of of race
or or gender i think it's more so just a
matter of establishing that trust
between the police department and the
community um
i definitely think how the verdict ruled
in in this
george floyd case it gave the public
more confidence that police
they have to be on notice with their
actions and they just can't go about
uh you know doing things the way they
want to do they need to follow
protocol or they will be held
accountable
cyril we're almost out of time i just
wanted to ask you finally i mean
obviously
you knew him as a boy and maybe later in
life i'm not sure but
but how do you remember george
you know i'm always going to remember
him as someone that wanted to help
other people i will always remember him
as someone that wanted to see
anyone who had a chance to be a good
sportsman to take
full advantage of the opportunity